cela ne vous aura pas échappé des
manifestations se sont tenues à travers
tout le pays à la fois contre
l'extension du passani terre mais aussi
contre la vaccination obligatoire contre
le connais 19 pour certaines professions
si d'emblée les manifestants sont
présentés comme des anti vagues sous des
complotistes
la réalité est toutefois plus nuancée ne
plus contrôler
enfin c'est une ultra minorité mais
c'est comme toujours c'est parfois que
ce goût ceux qui font le plus de bruit
même quand ils sont pas nombreux dont on
va parler le plus ça c'est ce que
dénonce et olivier ferrand le 16 juillet
2021 pourtant ils étaient plusieurs
dizaines de milliers à battre le pavé à
travers toute la france et vous faisiez
peut-être partie de ces manifestants
loin d'être étonnant puisque l'on
retrouve au sein de ces cortèges des
profils très hétérogène militants
politiques
jeune retraité soignants mais aussi des
jets les jours et pour cause si dans les
sondages le passé ni terre aucune
majorité d'approbation nombre de
français s'agace de voir l'espace public
désormais conditionné à la présentation
de données de santé
les gens qui sont descendus dans la rue
ce sont des gens qui dénoncent et depuis
plusieurs mois maintenant est-ce qu'ils
assimilent à une dictature sanitaires
c'est c'était d'abord un hashtag sur la
chaussée devenue un slogan à très fort
et un slogan qui s'est accompagnée de
plus en plus d'analogie considérés comme
étant des analogies très douteuse avec
la seconde guerre mondiale et puis
on explique que le pass and iter est une
manière de créer deux catégories de
français ceux pleurait plus de droits
que d'autres et donc d'instaurer un
apartheid c'est un bon utilisé par
florian philippot notamment et d'autres
pour décrire les situations casteret
surface éditeurs c'est quand même une
foule assez hétérogène avec d'un côté
des des gilets jaunes mais aussi des
familles avec des enfants qui ne se
revendique pas j'ai les jaunes
il y avait cette idée de dire on ne veut
pas qu'on vaccine nos enfants on ne veut
pas ils disent qu'on leur injecte des
produits je cite dont on connaît pas
provenance d'un côté on avait des
personnes qui se met un peu le trouble
dans ce cortège l'apprécient mais aussi
les des familles et des personnes âgées
elle le d'expliquer qu'elle ne voulait
absolument pas qui est la violence et
elle ne sont pas anti vaccins mais plus
antipas sanitaire ce qui ressort
effectivement c'est cette idée de dire
c'est mon corps en fait je fais ce que
je veux
le popoli père des primes immédiatement
les régions c'est vraiment une injustice
énorme et une privation de liberté je
pense que ce vaccin systématique c'est
une usure trop extrême est trop risqué
c'est pas anecdotique
le fait de rassembler autant de
personnes je pense pas qu'il faille le
minimiser il faut pas non plus en faire
quelque chose de révolutionnaire on
n'est pas c'est pas la prise de la
bastille non plus la foule mobilisée
fait écho en précédent mouvement qui a
secoué la france durant plusieurs mois
celui des jets les jaunes c'est un
constat qui est fait par les
renseignements territoriaux dans une
note publiée par le parisien qu'il
s'agisse de l'organisation des moyens
utilisés ou encore de la cause défendue
des éléments crasson de les deux qu'il
faut garder en tête que au moins pour
plusieurs années dès lors qu'on sera en
présence de manifestations j'allais dire
non encadrés par des corps
intermédiaires barre des syndicats des
partis politiques des manifestations que
l'on peut considérer comme assez
hétérogène et bien la comparaison avec
des gilets jaunes viendra assez
spontanément à d'une certaine façon ce
qui s'est passé en novembre 2018 avec
ses prolongements dans leur voiture le
1er trimestre de l'année 2019 à marquer
durablement les esprits
de la même manière que au moment dé
gilet jaune on faisait référence à au
phénomène mis debout clairement la
référence au gilet jaune avia assez
spontanément un parallèle avec le
mouvement des gilets jaunes qui à mon
avis est absurde puisque on retrouve des
figures du mouvement de gilet jaune dans
ce mouvement anti mesures sanitaires
antipas sanitaire le mouvement des
gilets jaunes étaient très difficiles à
appréhender et à fixer ses amants
protéiforme qui a évolué dans le temps
il finalement à cristalliser autour de
sa tombe de mots d'ordre mais ce qui
réunissait quand même tous les gilet
jaune c'était l'outil système sans
surprise cette même note précise que 65
% et chez les jaunes soutiennent les
mobilisations actuelles
si les mobilisations rappelle autant
celle des
les jaunes c'est parce qu'hormis les
préoccupations sanitaires le mouvement
semble porté par certains comme un rejet
de l'action gouvernementale et du chef
de l'état l'élément qui lis et relis
rassemble du traitement c'est quand même
la contestation à l'égard des modèles
battre pour ce qu'il représente pour ce
qui lui est prêtée comme intention est
de ce point de vue là ça ramène à une
partie du comportement qui était celui
des huiles et jaune mais ça ouvre aussi
une piste nouvelle dans la réflexion
c'est à dire qu'on est bien là d'un
comportement individuel avec une sorte
d'hypertrophie de l'individu versus
l'état à l'état organisé d'état
institutionnel
je pense que c'est ça qu'il faut avoir
en tête c'est pas tant tout ce qui est
autour de la problématique du vaccin
réflexion autour de la dangerosité du
vaccin qui est en cause c'est bien c'est
véritablement la critique globale d'un
système qui est ainsi contenue dans ces
manifestations pour des raisons
idéologiques d'une part et
d'opportunisme politique d'autre part eh
bien on a une instrumentalisation de
cette thématique pour je crois faire de
ce rassemblement autre chose encore une
fois les gens aujourd'hui se réunissent
contre le passé ni terre et dernière
c'était contre le port du masque avec
des arguments qui n'étaient pas fondées
scientifiquement aujourd'hui les mêmes
disent que les vaccins sont très
dangereux en revanche on voit les
acteurs plus petits les entrepreneurs
politiques se refaire une santé sur le
dos troupes
on a là des gens qui parfois ont des
propos publics marquée au coin d'une
très grande radicalité incitant presque
à la violence qui vont l'aider
sinon des contes collectés par choix de
manchons de toul
si les manifestations ont mobilisé plus
de cent mille personnes en plein mois de
juillet les experts interrogés estiment
toutefois que le mouvement pourrait
s'essouffler
[Musique]